il commence toujours par un dessin des
traits de crayon et la pièce prend forme
sébastien serveau n'est pas dessinateur
il est pâtissier chocolatier gelé dans
la tête mais entre ce qu'on dans la tête
et ce qui va être réalisable c'est pas
toujours facile donc j'ai besoin de me
poser d'être sûr sur un dessin avant de
pouvoir me lancer à la transformation
avec le chocolat en fait ça dépend ce
qu'on me demande des fois ça peut être
un par exemple un d'entre eux mais où il
ya plein de textures à l'intérieur donc
moi dans ma tête déjà j'ai mes idées
donc il faut juste que je le mette sur
un papier pour après me rendre compte un
petit peu de ce que ça va donner mais en
l'occurrence le dessin me met vraiment à
m'asseoir sur quelque chose ya pa après
à partir plus facilement sur mes essais
alors là c'est une petite quantité parce
que j'ai qu'un seul qu'un seul bateau à
faire mais après quand on travaille en
séries on travaille avec une poche
diplômé il ya plus de 25 ans il
s'oriente très vite vers la pâtisserie
de grandes adresses françaises pendant
20 ans puis à son compte
ce jour là sébastien met la touche
finale à un modèle autour de pâques
pendant deux jours il sera dans le gers
dans un lycée professionnel rouge
énormément en france mais surtout à
l'étranger
la semaine prochaine je suis au maroc
après j'enchaîne avec la chine
j'ai fait donc les etats-unis le japon
le mexique fin voilà beaucoup de
beaucoup de pays sont demandeurs de la
pâtisserie la gastronomie française le
consulting en fait c'est
un client qui me sollicitent pour me
demande bien particulière ça peut être
une création de cartes pour un
restaurant ça peut être un
renouvellement de carte aussi ça peut
être un établissement qui va ouvrir et
qui veut recruter son personnel qui veut
former son personnel manager aussi donc
ça c'est mon rôle je suis pas que de la
création que la pâtisserie puis il fut
aussi le management autre facette de son
activité depuis trois ans chaque mois il
distille ses conseils dans le journal du
pâtissier un magazine professionnel avec
le photographe thierry caron on a eu
beaucoup de retours positifs de la part
des lecteurs
donc il ya eu un sondage de fait et
notamment les professionnels que je
rencontre sur les salons ou quand je
fais des formations quand je me déplace
à l'étranger également donc des retours
très positifs donc c'est très
intéressant de voir que les recettes que
je peux mettre dans le magazine sont lus
mais sont aussi exécuté sébastien
serveau est aussi l'auteur d'une dizaine
de livres de pâtisserie de quoi vous
mettre l'eau à la bouche